today's video is sponsored by mine
the smart data assistant find out more
later in the video hey 42 here
for tens of thousands of years money in
one form or another
has been making the world go round
enabling
neighboring communities to trade with
one another
giving individuals an entirely new way
of gathering
wealth and facilitating the expansion
of countless empires throughout history
nobody knows exactly when money first
came onto the scene
because its origin predates written
history
for a long time anthropologists assumed
money was invented as a replacement for
bartering
but it turns out that in the entire
history of our species
there is no hard evidence whatsoever
for the existence of a society that
relied on barter
as the only means of exchanging goods
and that actually makes a lot of sense
because when you think about it
bartering is a terrible way of doing
business
for a successful barter to take place
you're going to have to rely on what
economists call a double coincidence of
wants
or in normal person words not only does
the individual you're trying to barter
with
need to have whatever item it is you
want
you also need to have whatever item it
is that they want
it's no surprise then our ancient
ancestors
needed a better way of doing business
it may be that the use of money first
arose
as a way for ancient humans to deal with
times when food was scarce
for example when prey species migrated
or forageable foods were out of season
money allowed neighbouring tribes who
may have specialized in hunting
different species
to trade with one another when times
were tough
helping both parties thrive of course
the kind of money we're talking about
here
didn't much resemble what your local atm
might spit out
today long before we had the technology
to mint
coins commodity money was the only show
in town
currency has changed a lot throughout
history
and do you know what the most valuable
currency is today
it's your data that's right companies
that you may have only used
once a few years back are getting rich
from the data
you gave them for free that's why
recently i've been using
mine a personal data service that helps
you to discover
and track your digital footprint and
also helps you to remove your personal
data from platforms and services
that you no longer use or no longer want
to be affiliated with
this minimizes your digital risks and
online exposure to avoid future data
breaches
before they happen so let's have a look
at all the companies that have my data
according to mine whoa 1327 companies
have my data apparently i've been a busy
boy
so let's see who's got my info
hmm i don't use outbrain anymore
and i don't want them to have my data
let's take a closer look at what data
they have of mine
so they have my financial data as well
as my email address
i'm going to reclaim that with mine you
can automatically send the data deletion
request to the company
from your inbox let's go ahead with that
and there we go it's as simple as that
the security of your personal data is
really important
after using mine i'm confident that i
have better control of my data than ever
before
and i want you to have that feeling too
so be sure to visit
samemind.com today the links in the
description below
to find out where all of your data is
and how to reclaim it
and mine is still free to use for now
soon
it'll be a subscription service so be
sure to get your foot in the door
today commodity money can be made up of
any high demand item that has intrinsic
value of some kind
things like peppercorns tea shells
and silk have all been used as a form of
commodity money in the past in italy
parmesan cheese has been used as a
collateral for bank loans
and for a period in medieval england
40 sticks of eels could pay your rent
for a year
prisons have long been something of a
breeding ground for new kinds of
commodity money because inmates in most
countries aren't allowed to possess
cash cigarettes are the classic example
but more recently ramen noodles have
become
increasingly popular as has drug-free
urine
i should stress these kinds of commodity
money
really are only usable in prisons i
tried paying for my sunday morning paper
with a litre of high quality drug-free
urine
just the other day and the lady behind
the counter
called the police arguably one of the
most
bizarre currencies of all time are the
rise stones
found on the yap islands in micronesia
these stone coins are circular in shape
with a hole cut through the middle
which may not sound too dissimilar to
those lovely shiny discs you find down
the back of your settee
but rhinestones have one significant
difference
they're absolutely bloody massive
the biggest measure up to four meters in
height
and weigh 4 000 kilograms that's about
as much as your average
male asian elephant and even the
smallest are around 30 centimeters
across
these coins were so large it wasn't
uncommon for them to capsize the boats
used to transport them and once back on
land it could take upwards of a hundred
men
to deliver them to their intended
destination
according to local folklore the stones
were first created
as a result of an economic trade between
two sets of islanders
the story goes that 500 years ago
a yappies navigator called anagamang
led a small group of men on an
expedition to the neighbouring island of
palau
around 200 miles away when they arrived
they were in awe of palau's abundance
of calcite a type of limestone which
glistens in the sun
this sparkly stone enchanted the yappies
with its
magical aura and so an agreement was
made with the palawans that the people
of yap
could help themselves to as much
limestone as they wanted
in return for certain goods and services
anagamang ordered his men to carve the
limestone into the shape of fish
and crescent moons but he soon realized
circles were far more convenient when it
came to transporting the large pieces of
rock
the hole in the center was added so that
the stone could be slipped onto a log of
some kind
making transportation easier still to
begin with
rye stones were little more than giant
souvenirs
to show off to the people back home but
soon the stones evolved into a
new and exciting kind of currency that
could be used
during important social transactions
like marriages
and political deals or even to purchase
food you might be wondering how exactly
the yappies made this system work
considering the somewhat inconvenient
near
immovable weight of their pockets change
did every yappies own a house-sized
piggy bank
and horse-drawn wallet i wish the answer
was yes
but the yappies came up with a far
simpler solution
once a rye stone reached its destination
it stayed there forever even if a trade
was made
and ownership of a stone changed the
stone itself
would remain exactly where it had been
placed
after arriving on the island this even
extended to those stones which had
capsized boats
and sunk to the bottom of the ocean the
submerged stones
didn't lose their value and could still
be traded
by word of mouth of course a great deal
of honesty was required
in order for the system to function
smoothly transactions of unseen
rise stones would only take place if the
islander in question
was considered a well-respected member
of the community
and if the oral history of the
particular stone
was well established after all it
wouldn't have been hard for some bright
spark to start bragging about his
incredible wealth in rhinestones that
had
all been conveniently lost at sea
the value of each rye stone wasn't just
determined by its size
many other factors were taken into
consideration including
how difficult it had been to obtain the
rock used to make the stone
the quality of the carving was also key
as was the reputation of its craftsman
finally a stone's worth could be
affected by the transaction
it was being used for meaning it could
be worth
one thing for a wedding and another for
an inheritance
when irish american sailor david o'keefe
arrived at the yap islands in 1871 he
was immediately enchanted by what he saw
and in particular the rye stones in fact
he was so fond of the yap islands that
he cleared his busy schedule
and stayed there for the next 30 years
o'keefe saw an opportunity where others
had just seen
ridiculously large stone coins he
swaggered into town
like a rhiestone cowboy
i'm so sorry and unlike westerners
before him
he embraced island culture he even
introduced the yapis to more advanced
tools
which made the process of creating
grystones easier
than ever before o'keefe set himself up
as a trader
and soon established a reputation that
became known
halfway across the pacific he went on to
acquire his own private tropical island
where he lived with multiple yappies
wives
something he presumably didn't mention
to his wife back home in america
he was still waiting patiently for him
to return
as it happened o'keefe never made it
back home
his journey from yap ended in tragedy
when his ship was wrecked in a typhoon
and he was never seen again his 30-year
stay
on the island irrevocably changed yap
and his presence there
is still remembered by the islanders
today but
in spite of o'keeffe's good intentions
the tools he introduced
ultimately ended up having a damaging
effect on the yappies economy
seeing as a stone's worth was largely
dependent on
how difficult it had been to obtain the
new stones didn't carry anywhere near
the same value as the old
blood sweat and tear stones that had
been mined in the years before
o'keeffe's arrival somewhat ironically
the giant currency of yap
began to experience inflation
but not even a rapid reduction in
purchasing power
could knock the world's largest currency
out of its stride
in fact remarkably enough rye stones are
used as currency by the yappies
for certain special transactions to this
day
though regular money is used for
everyday purchases
it's pretty incredible that such an
unusual
not to mention impractical approach to
money
has somehow stood the test of time when
literally
thousands of other historical currencies
have fallen by the wayside
but then again maybe we shouldn't
underestimate
the ingenuity of rye stones i mean
the concepts they're based on are
actually surprisingly
advanced in fact when you think about it
rye stones have a lot more in common
with bitcoin
than they do with the loose change in
your pocket
i know i know that sounds mental but
hear me out
both bitcoin and rhystones rely on a
ledger system
to ensure the transparency and security
of transactions
with bitcoin this ledger is known as the
blockchain
a secure public record of each and every
transaction
that has ever been made rye stones use a
very similar system
though this time through word of mouth a
ceremonial gathering takes place
whenever ownership of a stone
changes hands where island chiefs
announced a transaction
to their subjects preventing stones
from being wrongfully traded with both
rye stones and bitcoins all of this
happens without the use of a centralized
banking system
which other forms of currency are
dependent on
giving the people the power to maintain
the economy
we think of these as very contemporary
ideas
but the yappies were using them half a
millennium ago
we even talk about people mining for
bitcoins
just as the yappies mined for calcite
on the island of palau 500 years ago
you know what screw dogecoin i'm off to
huddlesome rye stone
thanks for watching